[Music]  the chairman of the Barilla pasta  company is under fire for saying he  would never show a same-sex couple in  his pasta commercials yeah there's the  story he also said he's against gay  people adopting children and then if  anyone has a problem with his views they  can quote eat another brand of pasta now  a lot of people do have a problem with  his views and one pasta company is  taking advantage of it check this out  some pastas are straight some are not  straight it's how they come out of the  box at Paula Danza DiNapoli we know this  we make open minded pastas we use  straight wheat and Gabriel we use gay  eggs and straight eggs tired of  disapproving pastas try to Lanza  DiNapoli  for the man who likes painting the lady  who enjoys linguini and those who like  both  you